Music Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur fantastischen Jubiläumsfolge Folge 250 des Das-Podcast-Suppe-Podcast mit dir, Florin Team. Ja, danke schön. Vielen, vielen Dank für diese tolle Jubiläumsfolge. Haben wir uns natürlich einen besonderen Gast zuschicken lassen. Er ist natürlich hier Stefan Titzel-Bitzel-Titzel, er ist hier! Stefan Titzel ist da, hallo und herzlich willkommen! Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr mich eingeladen habt für diese fantastische Folge 250. Ja, endlich mal wieder! An... Name... Johannes! Johannes, der uns ein bisschen den Wunsch aus letzter Woche erfüllt hat, nämlich entweder das Clubleben zurückzuholen, endlich mal wieder auf dem Danceflasen.
Oder kürzere Entros, beides hinbekommen und fantastisch. Naja, es ist, glaube ich, in dieser Elektromusik verführerisch, einfach den Song sechseinhalb Stunden zu machen. Ja, Kommand C, Kommand V. Das geht ganz einfach bei Logic und so, selbst ich krieg das Sinn, den beliebig lang zu machen. Und dann denkt man auch irgendwann so, warum nicht? Ja, weil man schreibt es ja auch, das mag. Und dann ist es doch gut, wenn man maximal viel von dem, was man mag, aneinander reiht. Der akustische Musiker an der Fiedel muss natürlich den Ton halten, lange. Wohingegen der Elektromusiker, der Elektromatador einfach copy-pasted und das ist kein Problem. So hat es Johannes gemacht. Vielen, vielen Dank. Großartig. Und ja, ich bin richtig aufgewühlt ein bisschen. Es ist ein interessantes Gefühl, weil es ist sechs Uhr morgens, es ist wahnsinnig früh, es ist extrem früh. Es ist extrem früh. Und wir haben schon diese Clubhouse-Atmosphäre, das heißt, es ist so ein bisschen wie morgens aus dem Berghain raustaumeln und noch mal die ersten Sonnenstrahlen. Glauben wir, wir wissen es nicht. Ich habe eine Doku gesehen in Wild Germany, da wurde das so
beschrieben. Ich habe den Tweet zu einer Doku gesehen
und da war das so lustig beschrieben.
Ich bin normalerweise um halb
neun da schon raus und schaue mir
Pink Panther auf Super RTL an. Die Wiederholung,
die kriege ich jeden Tag.
250 Folgen aus Podcast-Ufo,
was sind deine Lieblingserinnerungen?
Uff, also, ich fange aber
Platz 60 an. Ich wäre so gut, wenn wir so Reinfahrpromis hätten und dann so Geld haben. Und Gido Kanzgut sagt, ja, das war eine super Erinnerung, das war eine Folge, an die erinnere ich mich noch sehr gut. Wir dachten ja alle damals, weißt du, diese typischen Char-Show-Reinfahrer und Olli Geissen führt durch die 250 Folgen. Was habt ihr damals gemacht? Welche Folge habt ihr damals gehört, als die Mauer fiel? Welche Folge habt ihr gehört, als der erste Mensch auf dem Mond gelaufen ist? gemacht, welche Folge habt ihr damals gehört, als die Mauer fiel, welche Folge habt ihr gehört, als der erste Mensch auf dem Mond gelaufen ist, welche Folge habt ihr da gehört, ich verbinde oft Podcast-Momente mit Real-Life-Momenten.
Ja, eher so eine Ampel, als mal einmal grün war. Ich habe es übersehen.
Ja, das ist meine Mondlandung. Also ich meine, so viel ist in meinem Leben nicht passiert.
Aber damals, als ich so auf die Ampel zugelaufen bin und genau in dem Moment, als ich an der Ampel war, ist sie auf grün gesprungen.
Das war mein One Small Step von mir.
Was sind eure grossen Podcast-Momente? Bestimmt so, keine Ahnung, dann vielleicht wirklich so die Moderatoren sagen irgendwas von Lebensmitteln, man ist gerade im Supermarkt und man hat plötzlich genau die Orange in der Hand, die gerade besprochen wird.
Man denkt, das glaubt mir niemand. Diese Momente können wir uns einschicken für die große, meine Lieblings Podcast-Momente-Gala-Folge, wo wir uns alle in feinen Zwirren anziehen. Folge 268 wird das sein. Folge 268, also die maximal unrundeste Folge. Am liebsten noch eine Primzahl-Folge. Ja, das ist eine Primzahl. Das finde ich ganz gut, eine Gala. Warum nur für Musik auf Podcasts? Wir brauchen keine Reinkommensstars, unsere Reinkommensstars sind unsere Hörer, die das Projekt tragen. Und da zum Beispiel, ah, Florentin hat mir erzählt, wie nervig es ist, wenn an der Kasse Leute ihre Waren so weit vorfahren lassen. Und ich stand an der Kasse und habe genau das erlebt. Unsere Hörer tragen uns, muss man sagen. Auf ihren schmächtigen Schultern, ja. Ja, aber man muss auch sagen, jetzt nicht der Gewissenablass. Also wenn da, dann sehen sie rechts plötzlich, ja, gemischtes Sack, links, jetzt lässt sie Geisterbahn. Und schon lassen sie uns fallen. Und lassen sie uns fallen. Wir sind halt wie diese Könige, die auf diesen Barren getragen werden. Oder wie so ein Vater, der sein Kind so auf den Schultern trägt und dann irgendwie so unter einer ganz niedrigen Brücke durchläuft
und das Kind so hinten runterfällt.
Und erst vier Tage später denkt sich der Vater,
da war doch noch so ein kleiner.
Ein kleiner dabei.
Wie ist der?
Podcast-Ufo.
Ah, der liegt noch auf dem Messegelände.
Der liegt noch auf dem Messegelände.
Und dann schön ins Taxi und zurücklaufen.
Und dann auch vergessen, was man noch mal da wollte. Was wollte ich jetzt hier? Einkaufen? Ja, das finde ich nicht so schlimm. Man taucht plötzlich beim Polizeirevier auf, verschwitzt und denkt sich, was wollte ich hier machen? Eigentlich ein guter Sketch. Eigentlich auch ein guter Sketch. So ein verstreuter Typ, der irgendwo ankommt und dann sagt, was wollte ich jetzt machen. Ja. Was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich machen. Aber auch so eine Leichtigkeit hat, so ein Grinsen im Gesicht, so ein, ja, so ist es vergessen. So bricht es so durch die Tür bei der Feuerwehr und dann, ah, jetzt habe ich es vergessen. Ich habe vergessen, was ich sagen wollte. Also ich bin ein Dusselkopf. Ja. Na ja. Passiert Ihnen das auch manchmal? Wir haben bösen Brände löschen. Hier, weisse Feuerwehr. Das Haus steht in Flammen und er so, ach ja, ich dummbeutel jetzt und wettbe zurück. Ach ja, aber du sagst es, ich möchte schon mal ein bisschen spoilern, denn wir versuchen nicht erst Spannung aufkommen zu lassen. Du hast gerade wieder massiv die Podcast UFO Community in die Kritik genommen, da möchte ich dir aber widersprechen, denn diese Woche hat die Podcast UFO Community richtig delivered, hat richtig abgeliefert, das nun mal als kleiner Vorgeschmack, denn ich bin sehr, sehr stolz und muss auch hier mal sagen, toi toi toi, ihr macht das richtig gut, ihr zieht diesen Karren fest.. Langsam, er hat sich festgefahren. Willst du das sagen? Er hat sich festgefahren und niemand hält an an der Autobahn. Man winkt, man ruft, wir hüpfen herum, manchmal wird ein kleiner Schneeball geworfen. Aber auch weil wir die Bahnwesten vergessen hatten, die im Blattraum normalerweise liegen. Die haben wir damals aus Spaß angezogen und dann haben wir sie normal in unseren Kleiderschrank gehängt, weil wir abends zu Hause gekommen sind und dann haben wir sie nie wieder ins Auto zurückgetan.
Es gibt diese Könige, die auf diesen Tragen von A nach B kutschiert werden. Die maximale Demütigung, also eigentlich, es gibt keinen krasseren Hochstatus, als von vier Menschen getragen werden auf diesen starren Stangen.
Und oben drauf sitzt man mit so einem aus, weiß ich nicht, Ästen gebastelten Krone und so. Aber gibt es da auch so eine Art ADAC, dass wenn der vorne links ausfällt, dann muss man rechts ranfahren, fahr mal rechts ran und dann muss irgendwie jemand kommen und dann kommt der ADAC, der auch so eine gelbe Ware von vier Leuten getragen. Und was kann ich aushelfen? Und oben drauf sitzt so der ADAC-Mechaniker. Was ist los? Ja, der Udo, der irgendwie kann nicht mehr. Vorne links, von links tauschen wir aus. Mein Knie, mein Knie, Schmerz! Udo, hol den Krankenwagen. Oder dann kommt der Krankenwagen.
Vier Leute kommen angerannt.
Es ist eine andere Welt.
Das ist wirklich eine Parallelwelt, so ein bisschen.
Und das freut mich dann immer, wenn ich das sehe.
Aber auch ein bisschen antiquiert.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es das gar nicht mehr.
Es ist ein bisschen altmodisch. Es ist ein bisschen old-fashioned.
Aber niemand weiß, was die wilden Hipster in Berlin, Neukölln, nicht so treiben. Ob die nicht einmal sein. Das ist der neue nach dem Hochrat, der neue heiße Scheiss, diese vier Menschen, die einen tragen. So vier Sklaven, die einen durch die Gegend tragen. Ist das die Zukunft? Nein, nein. Glaube ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, schnelle Raketen sind die Zukunft. Ja, und fliegende Autos. Das ist nach wie vor daran fest. An der 90er-Idee von Zukunft. Ich glaube, du hast, irgendwann steigt man morgens auf seine riesige Rakete, die einfach aussieht wie so ein Marschflugkörper, nur mit Sattel obendrauf und dann einfach damit zur Arbeit fliegt. Ich glaube immer noch an den Gyrocopter, dass der mal irgendwann durchstartet. Gyro im Sinne von? Gyros. Ja, aber inwiefern? Also es ist ein snackender Kopter. Man kann snacken zwischendurch, aber man kann vor allem auch fliegen. Also das ist wie so ein senkrecht startender Helikopter, der natürlich auch, also wie ein kleiner Helikopter, den du selber fliegen kannst, der nicht so schwierig ist zu fliegen. Das ist ein senkrecht startender Helikopter. Tatsächlich ein senkrecht startenderoppler. Der erste Senkrechtstaaten-Helikoppler. Nicht die, die die Kanzler aufnehmen. Wo man die erst schieben muss. Wo vier Menschen unten drunter den tragen, auf den Kufen. Das länderlich gut passt. Und dann müssen die ganz schnell über die Landebahn und dann so vorm Hügel werfen. Ja. Und dann Glück hat. Wenn er abhebt, pfeifen die sich. Glück hat. Zu viert immer ein bisschen links, rechts, und dann kommt man hin. Kein Helikopter, da kann man mit ans Ziel fliegen und man kann überall quasi landen, da ist keine Landebahn oder so, du kannst einfach quasi vor der Post, wenn du zur Post musst, landen. Sodass alle Briefe weggeweht werden. Schlechtes Beispiel, wenn ich Apotheke muss. Dann zu jemandem mit einem ganzen Stapel Briefe, ha, endlich sind die Hochzeitseinladungen fertig, heute kann ich wirklich ... Sorry, sorry, nein, Tietze, Tietze, Gyro-Technologie, nein, nie damit, der Gyro-Technologie. Aber gibt es da eigentlich einen Krieg zwischen Döner und Gyros? Ist Gyros nicht exakt dasselbe wie Döner, nur hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Stichwort Würze. Jetzt bitte weiter. Ich glaube nämlich, dass die einen das Gewürz sind. Weiter. Ich glaube, die einen sind eher türkisch, die anderen eher griechisch gewürzt. Mehr, mehr, mehr. Mehr Knoblauch. Schneid mir noch mehr Wissen ab von deinem Gehirn. Bei Griechisch. Geh doch noch mal ran. Länger ans Feuer. Ich habe kein Wissen mehr, leider. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es in etwa das Gleiche ist, ja. Kebab? Ist es auch nur das Fleisch oder es ist die Zubereitungsart? Ich glaube, Kebab ist die Zubereitungsart. Ist in Kebab schon der drehende Spieß mit drin? Ja, ja, ja. Das ist meine Frage. Ist der manchmal viel zu schnell eingestellt? Weil ich denke mir so oft, wenn ich einen Dönerladen aufmachen würde, ich würde den einfach so auf 160 Umdrehungen pro Sekunde ... Was ist die schnellste Geschwindigkeit, die du einstellen kannst? Das könnt ihr mal machen. Geht mal zum Dönerladen, eures Vertrauen und sagt mal, mach den mal so schnell, wie du kannst. Das ist ja auch nächste Hausaufgabe. Das habe ich noch nie gemacht. Tun sie es einfach. Schneller, schneller! Warum sollte das Gerät so schnell drehen können? Warum sollte man das einbauen? These, die Geschwindigkeit, in der sich dreht, hat nahezu keinen Einfluss auf die Gargeschwindigkeit. Jetzt kommst du. Ich glaube, nur der Abstand. Muss ich die Gegenthese machen, oder kann ich dir auch einfach zustimmen? Nee, du kannst auch zustimmen. Ich glaube, die Geschwindigkeit macht nichts aus. Ich glaube, der Abstand zur Heizwand macht was aus. Ja, da stimme ich zu. Ja, d'accord, bin ich dabei. Nichts Widerrede. Keine Widerrede. Nein, wir haben 250 Folgen gebraucht, um am selben Punkt anzukommen. Wir haben dieselben Meinungen, wir haben dieselbe Weltsicht. Wir tragen gleich Klamotten, sind der gleiche Mensch. Ja, wir sind komplett gleich. Und es ist immer so wichtig, bei Podcasts auch immer so auszutauschen, dass sich Moderatoren auswechseln, weil die nähern sich wie so zwei Magnete.
Nee, kein gutes Beispiel.
Nee, nee.
Eher die nähern sich an wie ...
So wie heißes und kaltes Wasser.
Dass es dann so lauwarm wird.
Und dann muss man wieder austauschen mit anderen.
Wir sind lauwarm, das kann man schon sagen.
Aber lauwarm ist sehr angenehm. Ich mag lauwarm, ist meine Lieblings-Temperatur nach leicht wärmer als lauwarm. Und bei mir wäre dann auf Platz drei noch leicht kälter als lauwarm, aber es ist ein knapper Platz drei, also Platz eins ist solide lauwarm. Ist lauwarm definiert mit einer Temperatur? Es ist zwischen kalt und warm. Nee, ich meine konkrete Grad Celsius-Zahl. Nee, es ist immer genau dazwischen. Es ist nichts kaltes und nichts heisses. Es ist genau dazwischen. Genau dazwischen ist lauwarm. Tolles Wort, gibt es das im Englischen? Nein. Lukewarm? Oh, die verdammten Füchse. Immer einen Schritt voraus. Diese Damn Brits! Those Brits. Lukewarm? Wie Luke Skywalker? Wie Luke Skywalker, ja. Vielleicht gibt es da Zusammenhänge. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Lau Skywalker? Eigentlich, wenn man genau ist, müsste er Lau Skywalker heissen. Also er ist genau zwischen Darth und Anakin. Wow, jetzt haben wir endlich Star Wars entschlüsselt. Nach all den Jahren ist Star Wars, der Star Wars Code ist geknackt. Lau, er ist Lau Skywalker. Aber was ist mit Leia, Laura? Laura. Laura Skywalker.
Also, ich hab auch immer das Gefühl,
dass wenn Namen so leicht anders wären,
so ein ganzes Franchise auch mal kippen kann.
Ja.
Wenn es Laurie gewesen wäre, statt Leia,
wären andere an andere Welt.
Ja, stimmt schon, ja.
Nee, Rebecca wäre genau gleich gewesen, glaube ich.
Rebecca gleich, aber Denise? Denise Skywalker. Denise Skywalker. Und statt Luke Skywalker vielleicht Paul Skywalker, wäre auch anders, weil Luke ist ja ein ganz normaler Name. Ja, Luke ist ein ganz normaler Name. Für englischsprachige Sprecher, deswegen für uns Deutsche war das immer cool und alle Lukasse zu der Zeit hießen dann immer Luke, oh nenn mich Luke, aber... Vor allem, wenn man sich damals mal bei Wikipedia vorher die Castlist angeguckt hätte, C-3-P-O, R-2-D-2, Obi-Wan Kenobi, Luke, und dann denkt man auch, Jabba, und man denkt, hä, Luke, was ist das für ein Film? Man würde denken, dass Luke Paul Richard, dass das kleine Kind Luke irgendwie in so eine Traumwelt abdriftet. Eigentlich schon, ja, vielleicht ist es auch so. Ah, ja, ich weiß es gar nicht. Ich meine, Lukas Hinterbichler passt halt nicht so ganz in diese Science-Fiction-Welt. Oder vielleicht hat sich Georg Lukas auch gedacht, na, Luke ist ein bisschen unterperformt, dann dreh ich beim Nachnamen noch mal so richtig Sci-Fi auf Maximum. Skywalker! Skywalker! hat er geschafft. Hat er geschafft. Hat er richtig geschafft. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Lehnt weiterhin unsere Interviewabfragen ab, leider, Lukas. Nee, das stimmt nicht. Er ignoriert sie. Ja, gut, wenn du so direkt werden willst, ja, er ignoriert sie, was manchmal besser ist, was manchmal besser ist, als nachzufragen, ah, okay, und wo macht ihr das? Ja, in Köln. Und dann nicht mehr zu antworten. Lieber, wenn ihr nicht antwortet, lieber gleich nicht antworten, als eine Nachfrage zu stellen und dann zu ignorieren. Das ist die George-Lucas-Methode. Ja, in Köln, auch vielleicht nicht die beste Antwort von George Lucas ist, wo nehmt ihr denn auf? Ja, in Köln. Keine Antwort. Antwort. Also in diesem Szenario hätten wir auch keine Antwort verdient, ehrlich gesagt. Wessen Antwort wir aber sehr verdient haben, ist die Antwort von unserer Community. Wir waren ja sauer mit euch. Wir waren ja, und vielleicht, also wir haben letzte Woche bemerkt, dass ihr eure Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht hat, alle ausser Jenny.
Alle ausser Jenny haben letzte Woche ihre Hausaufgabe nicht abgegeben und wir waren sehr sauer, wir haben da auch das eine oder andere Satzfragment gewählt, um euch zu beschreiben. Also da waren abgerissene Sätze. Also so sauer waren wir. Wir waren so sauer, dass wir einzelne Satzfetzen gegen euch verwendet haben, kann man sagen. Also da wurden gewisse Sentenzen verwendet gegen euch und ja, die Wortwahl war krude, muss man sagen, da möchten wir uns vielleicht in der Rückschau ein wenig von distanzieren, aber der Inhalt bleibt gleich. Wir distanzieren uns, aber der Inhalt bleibt gleich. Wir distanzieren uns, aber wir stehen weiterhin voll und ganz dahinter. Voll und ganz dahinter, aber wir möchten uns auch entschuldigen. Genau. Und deswegen möchten wir jetzt euch einladen in unsere neue Rubrik Sprache, Sprache, Sprache, Sprache, Sprache. Und zwar hattet ihr die Hausaufgabe bekommen, das Wort Moloch zu verwenden in normalen Konversationen. Am liebsten in einem beruflichen Kontext das Wort Moloch. Genau, beruflicher Kontext, wo auch immer ihr es verwendet. Vielleicht kann Stefan noch mal ganz kurz sagen, was Moloch bedeutet für alle, die es vielleicht nicht ganz wissen. Ja, Moloch ist sowas eine dunkle, verbrannte Erde Welt, oder nicht? Molocholoch ... Besser hätte ich es nicht ... Nee, das ist eine biblische Bezeichnung für phönizisch-kanaanäische Opferrieten, die nach der biblischen Überlieferung die Opferin von Kindern. Also Moloch ist einfach ein Ort, wo alles drunter und drüber geht. Ja, Moloch ist was ganz Schreckliches, was enorme Opfer erfolgt. Höllenartig. Höllenartig,
grauenvoll,
schrecklich und eine Fernsehserie aus Frankreich. Ja,
und Marcel schreibt uns,
der hat allerdings das Wort Maloche benutzt.
Ähm,
also Marcel, er hat die falsche,
er hat gesagt, sorry,
ich habe jetzt Aufgabe B gemacht. Genau.
Also da, danke Marcel für deine Nachricht, aber es war nicht Maloche, es war Mollo. Aber er hat auch das falsche Carlsen-Buch vor sich liegen, das falsche Podcast-Uvo-Schulbuch, falsche Ausgabe. Ansonsten haben wir ganz viele fantastische Nachrichten bekommen, vielen, vielen Dank. Da haben dann tatsächlich doch noch mal einige ihr Schulheft gefunden, nachdem wir mal ein paar deutliche Worte letzte Woche gewählt haben, haben einige ihr Schulheft gefunden. Ich muss noch einen fiesen Satz fetzen gegen den Lieben, dass man sich finden. Also da war jemand natürlich, unsere Podcast-Suchfru-Community wäre nicht unsere Community, wenn da nicht auch mit ganz harten Mandagen gekämpft wird. Also, der liebe Altendollar hat nämlich unter meinen Tweet geschrieben, dieser Kommentarbereich ist ein Moloch aus mittelmässigen Insidern. Oh, nein. Schön? Nein, nicht schön. Ich habe gesagt, das geht nicht, klar, auf gar keinen Fall. Das kann, es muss im beruflichen Kontext benutzt werden. Okay. Haben wir denn Nachrichten bekommen, wo Leute jetzt das Wort Moloch im beruflichen Kontext eingebaut haben? Ja, zum Beispiel schreibt uns Johanna eine E-Mail, die sie an einen Arbeitskollegen oder Kollegin geschrieben hat. Und sie schreibt, keine Sorge, dein Schreiben ist nun angekommen. Es ist doch nicht dem Moloch der Post zum Opfer gefallen. Wow! Sehr gut, finde ich sehr schön. Wenn die Antwort nur ein Fragezeichen wäre, wäre das nicht so schlecht. Wie Jeff Bezos, der gerne mal ein Fragezeichen schickt, einfach nur in seine Bilder. Ne, keine Antwort, aber ansonsten. Ich habe auch noch ein paar. Er schreibt uns auch noch ein anderer Marcel, der uns schreibt, der anscheinend in irgendeiner Weise mit Fotos arbeitet, vielleicht ist er Fotograf oder sonstiges in der Richtung, und er schreibt, soll ich es dann, also in einem Text, den er schreibt, soll ich es dann doch eher positiv darstellen, oder muss ich trotzdem nochmal in dieses Moloch aus 4000 Fotos abtauchen und die mehr von den unangenehmen Situationen raussuchen? Also, auch hier sehr kreative Wahl. Aber ehrlich gesagt, klang das passivaggressiv. Also ich glaube, ja, also wahrscheinlich, wenn man das Wort Moloch benutzt, schwingt immer so ein, muss ich jetzt ab, also er hätte sonst formuliert wahrscheinlich, oder soll ich die anderen Fotos nochmal durchsuchen?
Ja. Oder muss ich nochmal abtauchen in das Moloch? Klingt halt automatisch nach, ja, dann mach's halt nicht, sorry.
Ja, finde ich aber super, weil man einerseits ein sehr gebildetes Wort benutzt, gegen das der andere nicht widersprechen kann, weil man sich sofort eingeschüchtert fühlt und man sich denkt, okay, also der kann ja nicht, man kann ja nicht wirklich sauer sein und das Wort Moloch verwenden, oder? Also das ist ja so ein Wort, wo die Emotionalität schon zurückgenommen ist. Das ist schon so eine gewisse kontrollierte Wut eigentlich, eine rationale Wut. Auch lustig wäre, wenn ein Podcast-Uvo-Hörer von einem Arbeitskollegen eine Mail bekommen hätte mit dem Wort Moloch. Wow. Und dann Hörerinnen und Hörer sich zum Beispiel kennenlernen oder sowas. Finde ich gut. Lars schreibt, ich habe die beiden Verbesserungen noch eingearbeitet, auf dem Fragebogen hat sich da natürlich was verschoben, ich habe mich dann nochmal ins Moloch von CSS begeben und jetzt funktioniert es wieder. Und CSS so, I'm standing right here. Ich hab einen Screech bekommen von Daniel. Also es ist ein sehr typischer Berufsverlauf bis dahin. Gerade er ist gesehen, hatte JF mit EM, bla bla bla. Und dann schreibt er noch mal dazu. Diese Nummer, von der du mir vorhin am Telefon erzählt hast, ist schon ein ganz schönes Moloch. Wow. Wir wissen nicht, um was es in diesem berüchtigten Telefonat ging, aber okay. Und sehr schön fand ich auch die Nachricht von Lucy, die in, die schreibt in einem Gruppenchat und anscheinend auch irgendwas mit Informatik zu tun hat, und zwar schreibt Lucy, dieses Testen und alle Versionen am Laufen zu halten, ist aber auch echt ein Moloch.
Antwort darauf, ein was?
Was ist ein Moloch?
Lucy antwortet, eine grosse Aufgabe, bodenlos tief und so, zurückkommt tilde tilde und immer dunkler, je tiefer man geht, wie ein Ozean. Also, na gut, also streng genommen nicht, aber naja. Also ja, aber finde ich gut, finde ich schon mal schönen Ansatz auf jeden Fall. Und dann hat die liebe Susanne mir noch geschrieben, ein Screenshot mit dem Satz, brauchen wir in unserem Moloch der ESD-Bestückung einen offiziellen Ferienarbeitsplan? Und auch hier ist es suggestiv, also man will schreiben, nee, brauchst du nicht machen, weil das Wort Moloch automatisch so eine Aggressivität mitschwingen lässt. Ja, finde ich richtig gut, man kann da quasi nicht drauf antworten, richtig. Also das finde ich schon sehr gut. Vielen, vielen Dank für unsere ganzen Nachrichten. Wir werden da auch die weiter noch raushauen. Ansonsten vielen Dank. Finde ich sehr, sehr gut, sehr gut gelungen. Und ja, das war Moloch. Also wir entschuldigen uns in aller Form. Ja, ihr habt's drauf, ihr habt die Hausaufgaben gemacht, ihr habt sie gelernt. Wie gesagt, viele haben auch geschrieben, dass die irgendwo in der Post hängen geblieben sind oder die Mail im Ausgang hängen geblieben, weil man irgendwie dann das Internet ausgefallen ist oder so. Wir haben da vollstes Verständnis dafür. Wir glauben das auch alles. Wir glauben alles. Jede einzelne Ausrede. Viele haben gesagt, dass irgendwie auch beim Nachbarn die Leitung ausgefallen ist und die hat dann auch eine Sprachnachricht vom Nachbarn und alles.
Also das absolut toi toi toi, von daher überhaupt kein Problem und ja, vielen Dank für eure Einsendung.
Vielen Dank, das war die Rubrik Sprache, Sprache, Hausaufgabe, okay, ja. Zum Thema Hausaufgabe hat uns auch Caro einen fantastischen Kommentar geschrieben, weil wir haben ja gesprochen über diese perfekte, nicht überbietbare Ausrede, wenn man seine Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht hat, einfach zu sagen, ah, ich habe die 8b gemacht, ich wusste nicht, dass wir die 8a auf hatten. Und da schreibt uns Caro eine sehr lustige Anekdote aus ihrer Schulzeit. Die schreibt kleine Story zum Thema A, ich dachte, wir hatten die Acht E auf und nicht die B.
Ein Klassenkamerad hat diesen Move in der elften Klasse Deutschunterricht versucht, allerdings ohne sich vorher, in Klammern clever, besagte Aufgabenstellung durchzulesen. Stellte sich raus, die Aufgabe, die er also angeblich aus Versehen statt der richtigen gemacht hat, war die szenische Herausarbeitung und Darstellung der Beziehung zweier literarischer Figuren. Anstatt an diesem Punkt aber einfach seine Niederlage einzugestehen, hat er es durchgezogen und über fünf Minuten eine Szene über die Beziehung zwischen Tollers Hinkemann und seiner Frau improvisiert. Selten habe ich eine Performance gesehen, die so unterwältigend und gleichzeitig so beeindruckend war.
Wahnsinn!
Richtig gut.
Finde ich eine richtig gute Idee zu sagen. Aber da muss doch auch wirklich der Lehrer einfach, das muss doch der Augenschmaus sein. Dafür wird man doch Lehrer. Aber dafür wird man auch Schulbuchautor. Autor, weil ich meine, was glauben die denn, in was für einer Welt wir leben, wo man als Schüler nicht gemobbt wird, wenn es eine Achte nach dem Motto als szenische Herausforderung in einer Beziehung zwischen zwei literarischen Figuren, was dann Quatsch, wie gemein ist diese Aufgabenstellung allein schon. Die wollen doch Schüler einfach gegrillt sehen. Irgendwann läuft jemand in diese Falle und da ist tatsächlich jemand reingefallen. Aber ich glaube, Lehrer haben generell viel Spaß. Zum Beispiel hat uns auch ... Die große Community-Folge. Zum Beispiel hat uns auch ein Lehrer geschrieben, der die Aufgaben verteilt hat für Australien-Referate. Ja. Anscheinend ist es ... Hellwach. Ich bin hellwach. Anscheinend ist es Thema gerade Australien bei denen. Und er oder sie ... Bei uns war nie in irgendeinem Fach Australien das Thema. Nee, ich auch nicht. Und deswegen hat er eine Liste von Referatsthemen zu Australien rausgegeben, an seine Schüler, die Referate halten. Kängurus, Beutel und so eine Brainstorming-Assoziationsliste zu Australien, oder? Im Grunde so ist es einfach. Käng, Spinne, Krokodilhunter, die Liste lautet Sydney, Melbourne, Canberra, Aborigines, Ayers Rock, The Great Barrier Reef, Entdeckung und Besiedlung Australiens, Olympische Spiele in Sydney 2000, Steve Urban,, The Crocodile Hunter, Australion, The Commonwealth, Australion. Einfach mal gucken, was kommt. Solche Themen würde ich nämlich als Referenzthemen rauskommen. Einfach mal solche Themen und einfach mal schauen, was kommt. Das vergessene Pokémon, Australion. Vor allem, ich finde auch die Vorstellung so gut, dass er schreibt Olympische Spiele in Sydney 2000 und die gab's nie. Ja. Es gab noch nie Olympische Spiele in Australien und irgendein Schüler nimmt sich das und denkt sich, das kann doch nicht sein, ich finde nichts dazu. Mega. Und dann guck mal, was der so erzählt. Guck mal, was der so erzählt. Der würde niemals in Frage stellen, dass der Lehrer sich das ausgedacht hat. Nein, weil als Lehrer gibt es ja immer so zwei, drei, die man wirklich hasst. Und denen gibt man dann die Referatsthemen zu Menschen, die nicht existiert haben, zu der ersten Mars-Mission Australiens. Viel Spaß, bis nächste Woche. Okay, ich gucke mal, was ich finden kann. Und das ist auch nicht schlecht. Und sein nächstes Thema ist natürlich Beuteltiere. Im weitesten Sinne. Im weitesten Sinne. Mal gucken, was da so kommt. Mal gespannt. Beuteltiere in Australien? Da gab ja auch so ein Referatstabu. Du machst ein Referat über die Beuteltiere Australiens, ohne das Wort Känguru zu benutzen. Viel Spaß. Und wie enttäuscht die Klasse ist, wenn du sagst, heute erzähle ich euch von einem Beuteltier in Australien. Dann sind alle, weee! Nach 20 Minuten kein einziges Mal Känguru gemacht. Und dann kommt diese, vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeitsfolie und dann großen Känguru im Hintergrund. Alle so, what? Und das letzte Thema ist, dass er seinen Schülern zur Auswahl stellt, ist der australische Dornteufel oder sein lateinischer Name Moloch Horidus. Nein. Also der Lehrer, der hat die Hausaufgabe gemacht. Der Lehrer hat die Hausaufgabe gemacht. Nicht nur Schüler machen Hausaufgaben, auch Lehrer machen Hausaufgaben. Sehr gut. Weil die wissen, wie sich das anfühlt, wenn die Leute, die vor allem wissen, das nicht machen. Richtig. Dankeschön, Herr Lehrer. Vielen Dank, Herr Lehrer. Er betitelt das Ganze mit Antenne Australien. Ja, lass uns das mal langfristig in den tiefen Beutel schieben, in den ganz tiefen Beutel stecken. Vielleicht kommen wir da eines Tages noch dazu hin, aber langsam, okay, langsam. Wie cool ist das denn? Aber man will ja auch, also jetzt will ich eigentlich Lehrer werden, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Absolut, weil du kannst ja auch gucken, was interessiert mich selber. Haltet mal Referate und dann denkt dir einfach Themen aus, die dich selber interessieren. Ich meine, man muss halt so sagen, Schülerreferate sind in der Regel grottenschlecht und mit, ja, Rudolf Weisinger wurde am 5.9. geboren, seine Eltern waren, das ist immer der Punkt, wo ich jedes Referat abschalte, ist, wenn jemand sagt, welche Berufe die Eltern hatten. Albert Einstein, sein Vater war Bäcker und seine Mutter war, ja who cares, interessiert mich doch nicht, dass der Vater von Albert Einstein krasser war als er, niemand interessiert sich dafür. Dass er Walfänger war, ja ja so what seine mutter war diamantentaucherin und sein vater walfänger ja ja weiter geht's e ist gleich was wir wollen was ist e wir wollen e weg mit diamantentaucher e will ich was ist denn e E? So muss ein Schein auch immer durch die Welt gelaufen sein. Mann, was ist E denn jetzt? Schatz, der Verrückte, der Verrückte läuft ja durch die Strasse. Oh, ey, was ist E, ey, fuck. Wissen Sie, was E ist? Entschuldigung, bleiben Sie stehen! Bleiben Sie stehen! Ich brauche meine Traeld. Bleiben Sie stehen! Polizei! Ich brauche meine Trage! Polizei! Ich brauche meine Trage! Kommt her! Schneller! Folgen Sie dieser Frau! Das ist auch so Taxi-Tragen eigentlich. Rennen Sie den Menschen hinterher. Ja, warum nicht? Wie viel PS hatte ein so ein Wagen eigentlich mit vier Menschen, die es tragen? Oh, gute Frage. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel PS ein Mensch hat.
Wie viel PS hat ein Mensch? Wie viel MS hat ein Pferd? Weiß ich auch gar nicht. Aber ich glaube, ein Pferd kann ein Mensch tragen, aber ein Mensch kann kein Pferd tragen. Jedes Pferd kann ein Mensch tragen, aber nicht jeder Mensch kann auch ein Pferd tragen. Ja. Oh, okay. Ja, okay. Aber wenn du nur ein kleines, angenommen, du hast ein kleines Pferd, und jedes kleine Pferd kann kein Menschen tragen, kein kleines Pferd, wenn alle kleinen Pferde, zwei kleine Pferde können ein Menschen tragen und zwei Menschen können ein grosses Pferd tragen. Ich glaube, so geht es. Wo ich sehr schlecht war, meine ich mich zu erinnern im IQ-Test, war die Fragen, diese Zusammenhänge. Wenn alle Pferde Menschen tragen können, können dann auch alle Gnus Menschen tragen. Und ich war so, was ist denn jetzt los? Kommt aufs Gnu an. Richtige Antwort. Und dann gab es die Antwort, ja, kommt auf das Gnu an. Oder, weiß ich nicht, diese Sätze stehen nicht im Zusammenhang. Was ja auch nicht ganz stimmt. Einige Gnus können Menschen tragen, war da oft richtig, wo ich nicht genau wusste, warum. Aber manchmal ist das so gefühlig. Aber angenommen, du hast ein kleines Pferd und du hebst es hoch und dann wächst es einen Tag und dann hebst es wieder hoch. Warum kannst du es dann irgendwann nicht mehr hochheben? Weil du wirst ja jeden Tag ein bisschen stärker. Ich glaube, weil der Wachstum der Muskeln nicht proportional im Verhältnis steht zum Wachstum des Pferdes. Aber warum nicht? Was? Aber warum nicht? Ja, ja, ich habe die Frage verstanden, aber du... Ja, weil du deine Tasse vor deinem Gesicht hältst, als würdest du dich verstecken wollen. Ich sehe dich doch, du sitzt doch noch da. Ich hätte doch gerade ganz toll die Frage beantwortet. Warum nicht? Weil Pferde schneller wachsen als Muskeln. Ja, aber warum nicht? Diese Frage macht nicht immer mehr Sinn. Aber warum wäre die richtige Frage gewesen? Du grillst mich hier, ey. Ist das hier ein Kreuzfahrhör? Aber ich will auch gern Polizisten im Kreuzfahrhör. Ja, ah man. Warum macht man so wenig Praktika eigentlich? Ja. Also einen Tag lang Polizist, einen Tag lang Lehrer, einen Tag lang wäre es nicht eigentlich besser, wenn alle jeden Beruf hätten, als anstatt dass jeder nur einen Beruf hat? Genau, wir wechseln alle durch, weil dann macht jeder seinen Beruf voll gerne. Benjamin Blümchen, absolute Erfolgsgeschichte, kann alles, hat ein LinkedIn-Profil, holy shit. Gibt es eigentlich einen Porzellanladen? Gibt es die Folge? Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Gibt es die Folge Benjamin Blümchen im Raum? Im Raum. Die unangenehmste Folge. Die ist so unangenehm, weil die Stimmung ist unangenehm. Leute unterhalten sich nur, man trifft zufällig seine Ex-Freundin und redet übers Wetter und Benjamin Blümchen steht einfach daneben. Ist einfach im Raum. Das ist nicht schlecht. Ich glaube auch, dass ehrlich gesagt die Benjamin-Blümchen-Autoren irgendwann hart ins Schwitzen gekommen sind, weil du hast ja so diese Liste der Berufe auf Wikipedia und die sind durch. Wie viele Folgen, Werner Blümchen gibt es 200, also irgendwann hast du echt ein Problem. Ja, ab vorgestoßen war 50 hat man mindestens ein Problem. Ein riesiges Problem. Aber ich sehe es genauso wie du. Ich glaube, wenn jeder jeden Job einmal ausüben würde, hätte jeder in den zwei Wochen, wo er diesen einen Job durchführen müsste, wahnsinnig viel Elan und Bock.
Problem ist Einarbeitungszeit. Ich glaube, die ist die Frage, ob was wir an Zeit verlieren als Menschheit, weil wir alle alle zwei Wochen in den neuen Job eingearbeitet werden müssen, verlieren. Erst mal wer arbeitet einen ein, weil derjenige hat den Job ja auch erst seit zwei Wochen gemacht maximal. Das ist ein bisschen ein Problem. Und ob man das nicht, ob man quasi, dass man wettmacht im Sinne von mit Elan und Motivation für den neuen Job, ob man diese quasi mehr Skills nicht verliert, dadurch, dass man erst wieder eingebettet werden muss. Auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube auch, dass die Erwartungshaltung stark sinken würde, weil stell dir vor, du bist beim Bäcker und sagst, ich hätte gerne diese Nussschnecke und dem Bäcker fällt die Nussschnecke achtmal auf den Boden. Ja, und man denkt, was ist denn jetzt hier los? Und dann sagt er, ich bin aber erst, das ist meine erste Woche hier. Ach ja, in Ordnung, so. Und so bist du ja immer. Also auch wenn deine Stromleitung überhaupt nicht funktioniert, da ist ein riesen Knoten drin, funktioniert null. Das ist echt das grössige Problem. Viel zu viel Strom aus. Und dann rufst du da an und sagst, habt ihr eigentlich einen Schaden, was ist los bei euch? Wir machen den Job, seit drei Tagen mache ich den Job. Ach so, ja. Man ist auch immer wieder neu überrascht. Die Frage ist, würde man dann wirklich noch irgendwen anrufen, würde man noch zum Arzt gehen? Nein. Nee. Naja, doch, du würdest schon zum Arzt gehen, da kriegst du halt eine völlig falsche Diagnose, der hört dann mit deinem Stethoskop auf deiner Akte rum irgendwie und ganz, der funktioniert gar nicht. Die ist ans Auge, man denkt, das ist kein Monokel, ich habe den Job letzte Woche gemacht. Den habe ich auch gemacht, das kann ich ihm mal sagen, da können sich viel Zeit sparen und der wird dann halt eine Diagnose geben und er sagt ja, ja, sie haben Syphil Regeln, Syphilis, wirklich? Syphilis, Syphilis, ich weiß nicht, eins von beiden. Ich kann mein Knöchel nicht bewegen. Ja, das ist, lass mich nachgucken, in den Büchern, dann macht man das, was Ärzte eigentlich auch machen, glaube ich, guckt hinten in den Bücherstapel nach, nach K wie Knöchel. Oder aber auch die einschönsamen Richter, die sagen, ich war letzte Woche angeklagt. Ja, genau. Der Räuber, der vor dem Polizisten wegläuft und sagt, und so lange, bis er der Polizist wird und er dann Räuber. Der zieht's um. Dreht sich alles um. Gestern bin ich dir hinterher gelaufen und heute du mir. Ich finde das ein fantastisches Gedankenexperiment. Was, wenn wir alle jeden Beruf maximal zwei Wochen durchführen? Hat das nicht in Finnland, Finnland hat doch alle schon mal gemacht. Ja, die haben also kein Bargeld mehr, Finnland kriegt jeder 80.000 Euro im Monat ohne was zu tun. Ach doch, Finnland hat doch, jeden Tag ist ein anderer Präsident, irgendwie heute bist du Präsident. Das ist wie so ein Planspiel, Planspiel Finnland. Warum machen die das nicht mal? Äne, also unsere Idee an die finnische Botschaft, versuch das mal. Ich will mir ein, wäre Finnland nicht der bessere Name für Finn-Klimansland geworden? Eigentlich schon. Finnland mit Finnland. Gibt es da Copyright-Schwierigkeiten? Warum nennt das Finn-Klimansland nicht Finnland? Ich weiß nicht, ob es da Schwierigkeiten mit der finnischen Regierung gab, dass die gesagt haben, neu, neu, neu. Ja, aber Finnland mit Y. Ah, das haben schon andere probiert, dass irgendwie Ditschland heißt oder irgendwie sowas. Ditschland hat ja auch versucht, ein eigenes Land aufzuladen. Ditschland und die deutsche Regierung, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee gut auch in diesen Podcast. Und ich möchte es auch besonders heute erwähnen, in der 250. Folge, weil in diesem Podcast geht es ja auch um eine gewisse Sicht auf die Welt. Das Podcast-Ufo ist ja auch ein Lifestyle, ein Lebensgefühl. Wir tragen in die Welt. Ja, weil wir durften uns nicht als Lebensmittel eintragen. Wir durften sich deswegen als religiöse Gemeinschaft eintragen. Als Lifestyle. Das geht, das kann jeder werden.
Das geht. Und zwar ein Video, wo ein deutscher, ich glaube Ausschaustudien, der gerade in Dänemark wohnt oder so, hat sich auf die Idee gekommen, dass Flaggen cool sind. und hat dann an alle
Er hat dann so einen E-Mail-Algorithmus geschrieben,
programmiert,
wodurch er quasi an alle
Botschaften in Dänemark, der ganzen Welt, also alle Länder, die eine Botschaft in Dänemark haben, schreibt, dass er Flaggen sammelt und ob sie ihm nicht eine Flagge zuschicken können. Ja, von ihrem Land. Und tatsächlich von jedem Land auf der Welt. Und er hat 116 Pakete bekommen mit Flaggen. Und alle waren so nett. Und ich finde das total fantastisch. Manchmal muss man einfach fragen. Und Italien zum Beispiel hat ihm sogar die Flagge geschickt, die vor der Botschaft hing. Die haben jetzt keine Flagge mehr. Die haben keine Flagge mehr. Die sind jetzt nicht mehr wirklich die italienische Botschaft. Eine riesige Flagge geschickt. Die sind jetzt eine Burger King-Tüten-Botschaft. Also ist schwierig. Er sam ist schwierig. Er hat geschrieben, ich sammle Flaggen, können wir eine schicken. Und Italien so, ja, hier habt ihr eine dreimal fünf Meter große Flagge. Deutschland fand ich ein bisschen unangenehm, so eine kleine Pappflagge, so eine Papierflaggefahne geschickt. So eine ganz kleine, ein bisschen unangenehm, ehrlich gesagt. Dafür das Land NRW hat ihm eine relativ grosse Flagge geschickt. Da war ich dann ein bisschen stolz.
Und dann kannst du so eine Rangliste machen, von welchem Land hast du die grösste Flagge bekommen.
Ja genau, was ist das coolste Land? Was ist das geizigste Land, was ist das beste Land?
Dann die Botschaft Guatemala hat ihm einen riesen Präsentkorb geschickt mit ganz vielen so Soßen, Salsa, Hefte über Guatemala, Tipps, Drinks, Guatemala-Drinks, Tipps fürs Land, Reisetipps, Reiseführer. Einfach so generelle Tipps irgendwie, wenn du erst die Socken anziehst und dann die Hose, das ist viel leichter. Lebst besseres Leben. Das fand ich fantastisch, aber die beste Geschichte war, dass ihn der iranische Botschafter eingeladen hat. Ja. mit dem vermerkt, dass er leider keine Flagge hat. Aber er hat ihn eingeladen in die Botschaft, und dann war er da, und er meinte, das wäre sehr unangenehm gewesen, weil es ja keinen Grund gibt fürs Treffen. Weil es gibt kein offensichtlich ... Das Flaggenthema war vom Tisch. Die Flagge war längst woanders. Aber jetzt hat der iranische Botschafter ihn eingeladen und er musste, hat er gefragt, vier Stunden lang in der Botschaft sein, weil der iranische Botschafter darauf bestanden hat, dass er bleibt. Oh nein! Aber dann hat der iranische Botschafter das gemacht, was er immer macht, wenn er kein Gesprächsthema findet. Er hat vorgeschlagen, wollen wir uns nicht vielleicht einfach Argo anschauen? Argo? Schauen Sie einfach Argo an. Lass uns eine Folge Fargo oder Argo. Ich meine, wir haben vier Stunden, lass uns zweimal Argo anschauen, oder? Okay. Fand ich fantastisch. Finde ich richtig gut. Ich finde, E-Botschaften sind eine fantastische Welt. Ja, und es zeigt ja auch, dass sie nichts zu tun haben. Nee, da kannst du auch locker Sitcoms machen, irgendwie die vietnamesische Botschaft in Berlin, nichts zu tun den ganzen Tag. Und was machen die den ganzen Tag? Die kriegen wieder so eine dumme Anfrage und müssen irgendwie für die Landwerbung machen. Aber ich fand das so fantastisch, er hat an jede Botschaft geschrieben, er hat so viele Präsentkörbe bekommen, also alle waren so happy über diese Anfrage, dass sie so unglaublich überkompensiert haben mit und hier hast du alles aus unserem Land. Wie gut! Und hier hast du die Staatsbürgerschaft. Ich fand das fantastisch, diese Idee. Und es zeigt auch, dass wenn man offen auf Menschen zugeht, einfach mal so, dass oft coole Sachen zurückkommen. Kriegt man Geschenkkörbe? Ja, man kriegt Menschen neigen zu Geschenkkörbe. Das lernen Aliens in der Alienschule auch. Das ist ihre primäre Verteidigungstaktik, einfach Geschenkkörbe zu geben. Ich fand das super. Ist so ein Geschenkkorb aber auch was Feines, oder? Und es ist nicht das erste Mal voll, es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass ich von der Botschaft in Guatemala Positives höre. Wirklich nicht. Es zieht sich ein bisschen durch mein Leben. Ja. Wir waren damals mit dem Sovi Kurs in Berlin, Berlin Reise, und mein Spanischlehrer, der auch Sovi unterrichtet hat, war dabei und ist dann in die Botsatemalas gegangen, einfach mal so aus Spaß, um Hallo zu sagen auf Spanisch. Und die waren so froh und er ist dann wirklich mit so einem Guatemala-Hut und I Love Guatemala-Shirts und so einem riesen Guatemala-Geschenkkorb, der gleiche, den der Flaggentyp bekommen hat, zu uns gekommen abends, hat er irgendwie Tequila gehabt und sowas. Also die Botschaft von Guatemala ist, glaube ich, ein Geheimtipp. Also wenn ihr in Berlin wohnt oder in irgendeiner Hauptstadt,
geht mal in die Botschaft von Guatemala.
Ich glaube, da ist Fun, Fun, Fun.
Ich meine, es ist eine gnadenlose Gewaltdiktatur,
aber sehr nette Botschaft.
Aber die Botschaft ist irre.
Coolste Botschaft, fünf Sterne.
Die schönste Botschaft ist ja eigentlich Kunst.
Das ist eine Superbotschaft, ja.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob es dir aufgefallen ist, Tietze, aber du hast letzte Woche die Welt verändert.
Im Positiven oder im Negativen? Das schauen wirelingelingeling, verändert. Das Podcast-Museum. Wart ihr nicht auch schon lange nicht mehr in dem Museum? Wie geil ist das denn? Hättet ihr nicht auch mal wieder Lust, ins Museum zu gehen, aber ihr könnt euch nicht so wirklich, oder ihr habt keine Lust? Nein, die Ammoderation habe ich erst sehr abgeholt und dann sehr verloren.
Oder ihr lebt nicht in Paris oder in New York, wo die tollen Museen sind und denkt euch, ach, wie soll ich eigentlich die wunderbare Kunst der Welt konsumieren? Ich liebe das, wenn die Bärbomben so Relatable anfängt, geht die nicht auch gerne ins Museum, aber es geht gerade nicht. Und ihr seid auch eigentlich ziemlich froh, weil die Frau in der Garderobe immer eure Sachen vergisst und dann nicht zurückgebt. Das ist mein Regenschirm, aber sie sagt, nein, das ist nicht ihr Regenschirm. Ich sage, doch, ich habe die gerade gegeben.
Ändern Sie es nicht an mich, ich war vor zwei Stunden, ich habe den Regenschirm auch gegeben.
Und sie sagt, nein, das ist nicht ihr Regenschirm. Ich sage, doch, ich habe die gerade gegeben. Erinnern Sie es nicht an mich. Ich war vor zwei Stunden, ich habe den Regenschirm abgegeben. Und sie sagt, nein, das ist nicht ihr Regenschirm. Ich erinnere mich an Sie. Sie haben nur die Jacke abgegeben. Nein, aber ich habe dann von Ihnen einen Regenschirm und gehe deswegen nicht mehr ins Museum, was aus dem Haus verboten, weil du die Frau ins Gesicht geschlagen hast. So, das kannst du halt nicht. Dann haben wir das Richtige für Sie. Dann haben wir das Richtige für dich. Denn Stefan Tietze hat letzte Woche den titanischen Brückenschlag gemacht zwischen Farbe und Klängen. Denn wir haben uns gefragt, wenn Farbe ja eigentlich nur Wellenlängen sind und Ton ja auch Wellenlängen sind, kann man das Ganze nicht kombinieren. Und das hat unsere Technikabteilung, unsere Community sich zum Vorbild genommen und hat Folgendes angefangen. Und zwar hat ein anonymer User Folgendes gemacht. Ein anonymer User? Ein anonymer User. Wir nennen ihn mal Van Gogh. Van Gogh hat Folgendes geleistet. Und er hat geschrieben, er hat angefangen, den Farbwert von jedem Pixel in einem Bild einer Wellenlänge zuzuordnen. Was ja einfach ist. Genau. Und er hat geschrieben, wichtig ist dabei, Graustufen und Pink haben keine Wellenlängen. Also könnte man sagen, Pink ist keine Farbe. Und später dazu. Diese muss man also auslassen. Der sichtbare Teil des elektromagnetischen Spektrums, in Klammern Licht, verteilt sich genau über eine Oktave, in Anführungszeichen, die grösste sichtbare Frequenz ist ziemlich genau doppelt so gross wie die niedrigste. Spannend. So konnte ich also jedem Pixel einen Ton zwischen C4 und C5, eine Oktave, zuordnen. Zum Schluss spielen alle Pixel gleichzeitig ab und er hat damit ein Bild in ein Ton verwandelt. Fantastisch. Und deswegen, falls ihr euch denkt, ich will eigentlich heute nicht das Haus verlassen, will aber trotzdem die große Kunst der Weltgeschichte genießen, dann seid ihr hier genau richtig. Können wir uns jetzt Monalise anhören? Wir können uns jetzt ein Bild von Van Gogh anhören. Es ist der berühmte Sternenhimmel von Van Gogh, der Abendhimmel, den der anonyme User für uns in den Klang umgesetzt hat. Also jetzt viel Spaß mit dem ersten Museumsbesuch in rein auditiver Form. Bitteschön. Das war Van Goghs Nachthimmel. Und ja, also vielen Dank, dass wir euch diese Weltkunst auch zeigen können. Das war das Podcast-Museum. Podcast-Museum. Was? Also du hast es geschafft. Du hast es geschafft, Stefan. Du hast es geschafft, die beiden Grundkonstanten unserer Welt Licht und Ton zu kombinieren. Eine ähnliche Idee hatte auch Jakob. Und Jakob hat sich gesagt, auch ich möchte Stefan Tietzes traumbar werden lassen. Ich traue die Braten nicht mehr. Und möchte die Kunst hörbar machen, Farben hörbar machen. Und was er gemacht hat, ist, er hat sich die Mona Lisa genommen von Dumm Vinci und hat allerdings diesmal sozusagen jede Pixelreihe einzeln von oben nach unten genommen. Also hat jeder Pixelreihe einen Ton zugeordnet und die von oben nach unten ablaufen lassen.
Das heißt, ihr müsst euch jetzt vor eurem inneren Auge vorstellen, wie sich dieses legendäre Kunstwerk von oben nach unten aufbaut.
Also ihr fangt bei der obersten Pixelreihe an und fahrt da nach unten fort.
So müsst ihr es euch im inneren Auge vorstellen, damit ihr den gesamten
Klanggenuss dieses Kunstwerks habt. Hier ist die Mona Lisa bearbeitet von Jakob. Ist das gruselig. Ist das gruselig. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet ein Bild vor Augen. Oh mein Gott, ich will mal vor, da wäre so ein Tod, Tod, Tod, Rache, Weltuntergang. Fünf, fünf, acht, drei.
Was? Was los? Also vielen Dank für die Mona Lisa von Jakob. Das heißt, ein kleiner auditiver Ausflug durch die grössten Kunstwerke der Menschheitsgeschichte. Das war das Podcast Museum. Aber ist das jetzt das Ende dieser Reise, oder gibt es noch andere Möglichkeiten? Es ist ein kleines Museum mit zwei Bildern. Nee, weil das gibt doch, also das kann man doch bestimmt anders noch darstellen. Weil warum kann man das nicht um auf Klaviertasten, also zumindest, ich habe auch beide Geräusche an mich verwirrt, das eine war einfach nur ein, das andere war dieser Eerie Synthesizer, warum kann man nicht zum Beispiel Klavier nehmen und dann so sagen, ah okay, der Wert entspricht in etwa der Wellenlänge, das kann man umsetzen auf ein A. Nee. Nee? Nee. Gar nicht. Nee. Okay. Ja. Also, ich meine, ihr musstet nicht an der Garderobe eure Jacke abgeben, ihr musstet nicht irgendwo rumstehen, also auch okay. Ihr müsst auch nichts bezahlen. Kompromiss.
Ist ein Kompromiss.
Ja, das war das.
Also wenn noch Fragen sind.
Genau, hat jemand Fragen zu den Bildern?
Also natürlich haben Ursprung gegeben zu ganz vielen hunderten Interpretationen über die Jahre.
Mona Lisa, wer ist sie?
Was ist ihr fucking Problem?
Ich hätte eine Frage.
Gibt es da noch ein Buffet?
Nee. Nee. Okay. was ist was ist ihr fucking problem und ich hätte vor allem gibt es doch noch ein buffet oder nee nee okay wie bitte nee ich muss nur husten so ach so okay wird es in zukunft mehr bilder
geben wir müssen allerdings vier stunden hierbleiben. Wir haben den Raum gemietet. Also, wir haben leider keine Sitzgelegenheiten, aber wir könnten Argo schauen, wenn ihr wollt. Ja, und es geht so ein zustimmendes Nicken, auch leicht erleichtert durch den Raum und alles. Also wir haben, wie gesagt, jetzt nicht mehr ganz vier Stunden, das heißt, wir könnten eineinhalb Mal Argo schauen. Okay. Der iranische Botschafter ist begeistert. Wenn wir direkt nach dem Abspann neu anfangen, schaffen wir es eineinhalb Mal. Okay. Okay, los geht's. Los geht's. Okay, ja, also, aber ich finde gut, dass wir zumindest jetzt an dem Punkt sind, wo wir nicht mehr nur wilde Behauptungen ins Internet streiten, sondern die auch dann verifiziert slash falsifiziert werden. Genau, also wir können nicht mehr träumen, weil die Podcast-Community mit ihrem massiven technischen Know-how unsere Träume zerschmettern. Mit ihrem Realitätshammer unsere Träume zerschmettern. Aber die Community ist auch in der Lage, alte Kindheitserinnerungen wieder aufleben zu lassen. Stefan Tietze, du hast letzte Woche erzählt von, ich habe es bis heute nicht ganz verstanden und habe trotzdem Albträume von dieser Figur, ein Schrottsammler, der bei dir zu Hause aktiv war. Ja genau, der hat Kinder und Schrott geklaut. Okay, und der hatte anscheinend einen
markanten Erkennungs-Klingel und den hat uns jemand zugeschickt.
Das ist der Erkennungston vom Klünkelkern, das ist das ... Das Letzte, was viele Kinder in deiner Gegend gehört haben. Ja, also was wir gelernt haben in Kamen ist, wenn man das hört, rennt. Die Grauen voll. Vielen, vielen Dank an Tobi vom Teezeit-Podcast. Also schaut da auch gerne mal vorbei, falls ihr euch für Tee interessiert, Teezeit-Podcast, denn der meinte, dass es bei ihm im Freundeskreis auch die Legende gab und die irgendwann diese Aufnahme machen mussten für ihre WhatsApp-Gruppe, weil die sich nicht mehr sicher waren, ob sie das nicht geträumt haben oder irgendwie in der Therapie aufgearbeitet haben. Ja, ehrlich gesagt, das ist auch so eine dunkle Erinnerung. Es existiert tatsächlich. Das ist eine Horrormusik. Das Ding ist, genau, man konnte damals, man konnte Schrott, ich verstehe mir so nicht, warum diese Musik existiert, außer zu dem Zweck, Kinder verrückt zu machen und die Leute, die da drinnen arbeiten müssen in diesem Wagen. Stimmt, ja. Weil du musst dir vorstellen, das ist so ein Pickup-Truck mit einem Lautsprecher oben drauf und die ganze Zeit dröhnt diese Melodie, die nicht cool ist, die ist super eingängig, aber halt wahnsinnig nervig.
Die dröhnt da raus und du fährst acht Stunden am Tag durch die Gegend und sammelst halt Sperrmüll ein. Und der Fahrer hat so ein kleines Keyboard. Und spielt die immer selber. Deswegen sind sehr viele Unfälle auch passiert. Also wenn er die Kinder nicht geklaut hat, dann ist er in die Reihen gefahren in die Gruppen, weil er nebenbei noch auf dem Keyboard diese Melodie spielen musste. Er war grauenhaft. Vielleicht klingt so die Mona Lisa. Das wäre so geil gewesen. Oh, das wäre gut. Das wäre meine fucking Crossover-Geschichte gewesen. Es hätte ja sein können, dass du zufällig aus Versehen nach der Ammoderation und so klingt die Mona Lisa dieses Pfeil abgespielt hättest. Dann wäre ich hier, ich wäre gestorben vor Freude, weil ich dachte, hä, die Mona Lisa klingt wie der Klingelkerl aus meiner Kindheit? Aber das ist ein Crossover, Klingelkerl meets Mona Lisa, das ist meine Sitcom, oder? Oh Gott, das ist ein Horrorfilm, das ist ein absolute Horrorfilm. Aber wäre es nicht besser, wenn eigentlich jeder so einen Jingle hat, irgendwie wenn der Postbote kommt und immer so einen Postjingle hat, so ein Posthorn, bis heute hatte die Post noch dieses Horn als Symbol.
Als Symbol. Wird kaum noch genutzt eigentlich. Nee, das ist schon so. Weil es der Postbringer ist in der Stadt. Fände ich viel besser. Das fände ich super. Oder der Pizzamann. Ja. Der Eismann hat's noch. Der Eismann hat's noch. Der Eismann hat für Elise gekapert. Auch nicht der beste Song. Der transportiert für mich nicht das Gefühl, jetzt ein Eis, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau, es ist schwierig. Aber du hast schon recht, Pizza bräuchte einen geilen Jingle. Da seid ihr auch gefragt. Ich meine, früher, als wenn du so ein adliger Ritter warst oder so, und eigentlich immer, wenn du aufgetreten bist, erst mal die Fanfaren erschellt sind, musste auch jeder gucken, dass er einen geilen Jingle hat. Ja. Das wäre eigentlich auch eine coole Serie, eine coole Figur, so ein mittelalterlicher Komponist oder Songwriter, der immer so bei den Adligen dann so die Fanfaren machen muss. Und der ist halt auch nur mittelmässig so, das kommt alles nur so mittel an. Und dann so als Fanfare. Ich hätte mir eigentlich ein paar mehr, also. Aber es ist eingängig. Ja, sehr eingängig. Ich hätte mir ein paar mehr Töne gewünscht. Ja, ja, nee, aber das Problem ist, der benachbarte Herzog hat schon eine sehr klangvolle und schillernde farbenfrohe Fanfare. Und davon müssen wir uns halt irgendwie abgrenzen. So ganz fühle ich es noch nicht. Mein Vokabular dahingehend ist sehr begrenzt, weil wir im Mittelalter, fucking Mittelalter leben. Wann ist diese dumme Mitte endlich vorbei? Wann ist die Mitte vorbei, wo geht es hin? Wo zwischen sind wir die Mitte? Ja, wo zwischen sind wir. Naja, wie auch immer, gibt es mehr Töne.
Ja, schwierig, wie gesagt.
Also meine Trompete ist
im weitesten Sinne eigentlich
eine Metallröhre,
auf die ich mehrmals drauf gehämmert habe.
Sind sie nicht der Postbote, der örtliche Postbote?
Dazu komme ich gleich.
Sie haben eine Menge Post bekommen.
Da ist viel los im
Ich finde nicht, dass sie als Postbote automatisch befähigt sein sollten, nämlich von Fahrern Dazu komme ich gleich. Sie haben eine Menge Post bekommen, da ist viel los im ...
Ich finde nicht, dass Sie als Postbote automatisch befähigt sein sollten, nämlich von Fahrer zu schreiben.
Wie gesagt, wir sind drei Leute auf dieser Burg. Ich bin gleichzeitig Postbote, Komponist und ihre Frau. Also es ist ...
Ja, das ist mir leid. Das war massiv falsch.
Sie sind ein kleines Herzogtum. Wie gesagt, die meisten Töne habe ich ... Nennen Sie mich nie wieder kleines Herzogtum. Entschuldigung, Merath. So, Schatz, jetzt kannst du Abendessen machen. Rüben wieder? Ja, was sonst? Was gibt's heute? Rüben? Rüben. Ach, du dumme Rübe. Du dumme, dumme Rübe. Geil, also ich bin, also eine Folge, die mich durch alle Gefühlslagen kreuziert hat. Wir haben tatsächlich heute mal viel aus der Community mitgenommen, ob das gut ist oder nicht, wissen wir nicht. Denn wenn wir in 250 Folgen eins gelernt haben, dann wären wir ohne euch.
Formel-1 geht wieder los, diese Woche.
Zwei Sachen gehen nämlich los.
Jetzt bist du bei irgendeiner Bahn oder sowas.
Macht ein Formel-1-Wagen für dich?
Nein. Doch, wenn die Bremsen oder ...
Nee, das sind Podracer. Zwei Sachen gehen los. Am Wochenende geht's los. Formel 1. Und Zugzwang. Das grosse Schachturnier von Rocket Beans TV, wo ich dabei bin. Ob das sich Stefan fanatisch vorbereitet seit Wochen, quasi nichts anderes mehr tut. Das stimmt leicht. Ich trainiere ab und zu, aber es macht wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Mein Schach-Hype ist nach wie vor völlig am Start. Und ich trainiere mit einem ehemaligen Rocketbeats-Mitarbeiter, dem Raphael, zusammen bei Twitch. Folgt uns auf allen Kanälen, dann könnt ihr uns zugucken beim Trainieren, wenn ihr Bock habt, auch auf Schach. Wie folgt man dir? Man kann mir ja folgen. Wenn man das mit Podcasts hört, folgt man mir ja bei Twitter oder so, auf Instagram und dann kann ich da die Kanäle verlinken. Schaut Zugzwang, das wird fantastisch, das wird ein tolles Turnier. Ja, Steff, ihr könnt dabei zuschauen, wie ihr Schach spielt und ich hoffe, dass die Moderatoren auch immer diesen Clip einspielen können, wo über dich gesagt wird, du bist der begnadetste Spieler der Geschichte. Wenn ich frage, wie mir der Bauer ziehen kann nochmal. Wenn du aus Versehen drei Läufer aufs Feld stellst, der begnadetste Spieler der Geschichte, das will ich auf jeden Fall miternehmen. Das war total damals und ich die ganze Zeit so, sorry, ist irgendwas falsch, man kann den Bauer nicht rückwärts ziehen, man kann ihn nach hinten ziehen. Ist der Stefan Tietze der begnmiede der Geschichte. Also, das hat alles kaputt gemacht, bin ich ganz ehrlich, der Druck ist enorm. Ja, der Druck ist enorm. Wie gesagt, ich habe gesagt, du hättest aufhören sollen, deine Schachkarriere an den Nagel hängen sollen, aber du hast es nicht getan, du wolltest weitermachen. Ich habe davor Zugzwang zugesagt, jetzt Teilnahme. Jetzt bin ich da drin, gefangen und so und ja, wird auf jeden Fall schwierig. Mein nächstes Spiel ist, glaube ich, nächste Woche Montag, Also ich freue mich, wenn ihr zuschaut und mich unterstützt. Ja, macht das. Haut ein paar Gutschachs im Chat. Ich weiß nicht, was so der Schlachtruf ist. Ich glaube, man muss leise sein. Ganz leise sein. Ich freue mich sehr, wenn ihr zuschaut. Ich freue mich sehr aufs Turnier. Und generell, coole Sache. Ja, coole Sache, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, es ist ein Fehler. Ich glaube, man muss im Leben, wenn man einmal was erreicht, sofort aufhören. Sofort aufhören, wenn du als Fussballer ein Tor geschossen hast, sofort Karriere beenden, damit du nicht in die Bredouille kommst, zu sagen, der Druck ist so hoch. An früheren Erfolge gemessen zu werden. Nein, ein Tor auf dem Basketballcourt, ein Korb, weg. Sagen Leute, ich bin raus, holt euch einen Hotdog aufweg nach draußen, schön auf dem Parkplatz und raus. Ja, eigentlich schon, das stimmt schon. Also, es ist ein bisschen, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine gute Lebenseinstellung ist, weil es klingt wahnsinnig feige und blöd. Nein, sofort bei jedem ersten Erfolgserlebnis, sofort Karriere beenden, weglaufen. Ich glaube, ich langefristig gut für den Gemütszustand. Also, der Druck, den ich empfinde, der ist wirklich nicht schön. Und den hätte ich zum Beispiel hätte ich nicht mit deiner Lebenseinstellung. Soweit du auch nur ein Pferd geschlagen hast auf dem Spielbrett, weg. Quitten. Sofort raus, das reicht mir. Das reicht mir. Man muss sich auch mal selber Ziele setzen, nicht immer die Ziele von anderen übernehmen, sondern einfach zu sagen, ich würd gern einen von diesen Länglichen mit der Ritze oben drin schlagen. Mehr will ich nicht.
Mehr will ich nicht. Und dann ist es auch besser.
Ich finde eh das so in dieser Sportlerwelt
und so, die viel zu hart zu sich
sind, immer mal finde ich. Zum Beispiel dann irgendwie
Fussballer irgendwie, die dann
irgendwie so den Ball, also
das Leder, das Leder ins Eckige,
das Leder dann, sag ich mal,
schön von der
Mittellinie richtig reinschlänzen, also versuchen und dann hinten antreten, also dem Ball hinten an einen Tritt versetzen quasi mit ihren Stollenschuhen. Und der, wie soll ich sagen, der Ball dann katapultiert wird von diesem festen Tritt und dann fliegt und sich durch die Luft wirbelt auf das Gestell zu, um das es ja geht. Um das es letztlich geht, ja. Um das es letzten Endes geht und also darauf zu rast, also unaufhaltsam. Aber dann leider in letzter Sekunde es sich anders überlegt und die Luftverwirbelung natürlich auch noch ein Wort mitzusprechen haben und sagen, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah. Unwidrige Bedingungen. Richtig, widrige Bedingungen, Wetter hoch, Wetter tief. Und dann das Leder, dann eines Aluminium. Richtig. Versetzt, verfrachten. Und ja, sag ich mal, den Heerenträumen des Schützen ein jähes Ende bereiten. Und ja, dann aber oft, was ich beobachtet habe, die Spieler sich oft ärgern, weil der nicht reingegangen ist.
Ja.
Also wenn sie den sozusagen gegen die Latte gelatzt haben, dann sich ärgern.
Wo ich immer sagen würde, Alter, das ist ein mega guter Schuss gewesen.
Freu dich, dass es überhaupt in die richtige Richtung geschafft hat.
Wo ist die Faust nach so einem Schuss?
Ja, da würde ich so, naja, vielleicht keine Faust, aber schon mal in die Kamera kommen. Doch, so eine Faust.
Ach, Alter.
Nur Faust.
Ja, so, der war ein guter Schuss, oder? So Schultern hoch und so ein guter Schuss. Versuch du mal überhaupt ansatzweise was zu treffen. Hast du eine Ahnung, wie lange es dauert, in die Schuhe zu kommen? Wie ungemütlich das ist? Also ich finde das immer schade. Würde ich mich auch freuen, wenn dieser Moment kommt, wo plötzlich alle Spieler sich Richtung Kamera drehen und Richtung Kamera sagen, der macht halt besser. Nein, der war doch. Der war doch gut, der war gut. Der war nicht schlecht. Und auch der Gegenspieler kann sagen, Mensch, toller Schuss. Leider nicht reingegangen. Wenn es nicht perfekt ist, dann ist es sofort Niederlage. Nicht perfekt gleich schlecht im Sport, das ist Quatsch. Nee, das ist Quatsch. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ich mal so zwei Meter am Tor vorbeischießen würde. Wir sagen, ja, war nicht schlecht. Gut, das muss man jetzt sagen, woher die Argumentation von Florian Tine kommt, ist ja beim ersten Turnier Zugzwang in Runde eins sofort rausgefallen. Wie gesagt. Das furchtbare Spiel, und da muss man auch mal sagen, daher kommt dann auch gerade diese Ausflucht. Ich sag mal so, ich habe den richtigen Raum gefunden, ich war pünktlich anwesend. Es waren viele Sachen richtig gelaufen. Da lief fast alles richtig. Alles lief richtig. Schienen, ich hatte Kleidung an, ich sah präsentabel aus. Schienen? Ich hatte meine Schienen dabei. Also alles lief gut. Alles lief sogar mehr gut, als man denkt. Und deswegen finde ich es immer so schade, dass Leute das dann wegen einer Mein Gott, dann hast du halt nicht gewonnen oder mein Gott, dann ist da halt irgendwas runtergefallen, dass sie es dann danach bewerten.
Das meiste lief gut, das meiste lief richtig gut.
Das meiste lief richtig gut.
Mal ein bisschen die Ansprüche runterschrauben, Leute.
Ja, muss ich machen. Ich mache mir zu viel Druck durch diese ganze Jahrhundert-Talent-Geschichte.
Ich will aber auch einfach nur Rüst am Kaspar nicht enttäuschen.
Wenn der mitbekommt, dass ich dann Runde eins rausfliege, wie uncool wäre das denn, ehrlich gesagt. Euer Verhältnis wäre auf immer zerrüttet. Ja gut. Aber was mache ich, wenn ich das nächste Mal Rüster und Kasimtschanov über den Weg laufe, wenn wir uns in der Fußregel-Ruente sehen? Grüßt man sich eigentlich unter Schachspielern? Also wenn man so, also wenn du, du spielst ja online gegen Harry Acht oder so und dann, was ist, wenn man sich auf der Straße begegnet? Nt man sich da kurz zu? Nee, ich glaube, man macht sich die richtige Schachspieler, man vermeidet Augenkontakt und Körperkontakt. Ach so. Und Schachspieler sind zudem auch nicht an der frischen Luft anzutreffen, von daher, ich glaube, wir sind alle safe. Also wenn man aufeinander zugehen würde, würde man sich sozusagen umeinander herumschlängeln, sodass man sich möglichst nicht sieht. Tanzartig quasi den Rücken zudrehen. Dass es fast wieder cool aussieht. Der eine beugt sich nach vorne und der andere limbo-mässig nach hinten. Und dann läuft man untereinander. Zu dem Soundtrack von Queens Gambit läuft man dann schnipsend durch die Straße. Oder der eine kauert sich auf dem Boden zusammen und der andere nimmt Anlauf und hopst über den mit so gestreiztenreizten, tollen Beinen nach vorn und hinten weg drüber. Es ist ja oft unangenehm, wenn man Leute auf der Strasse hilft, die man kennt. Man will sich nicht begegnen, die man kennt. Man will auch nicht miteinander reden. Grüßen sich Tiere eigentlich, wenn sich jetzt so in der Wildnis zwei Koalas zufällig über den Weg laufen, gibt es da so ein kurzes zwei Finger an die Stirn? Yo, gut Panda. Was gibt Koala? Ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Erkennen sie sich selber oder denken die, das wäre ein Spiegel? Verdammt viele Spiegel hier. Kennen die das Konzept Spiegel überhaupt, dass sie denken, bin ich das selber, sehe ich mich gerade selber und dann heben sie den Arm hoch? Es muss extrem verwirrend sein für ein Tier, weil wenn die einmal einen Spiegel gesehen haben, können die danach ja nie wieder irgendjemandem trauen. Ihm ihm Vertrauen. Weil die sehen ja alle, das ist auch ein bisschen rassistisch zu sagen, dass alle Tiere exakt gleich aussehen, für uns natürlich schon, aber für die ja nicht. Das finde ich auch nicht. Findest du, jeder Hund sieht gleich aus? Ja, ja. Also so bei Pandabären würde ich mir schon schwer tun, die zu unterscheiden. Ne, aber die haben andere Flecken. Gut, stimmt.
Aber ist es nicht auch so, dass wenn die
zu weit... Genau, wie diese Schmetterlinge, die nummeriert sind, die
hier war noch, dass ich finde.
Aber da hat die Natur immer mitgedacht. Aber ist es
nicht auch so, dass wenn die Tiere zu weit
voneinander entfernt sind, dass sie sich dann nicht mehr grüssen
auf der Strasse? Also, dass man so zwei
Hunde nicken sich zu, aber
Hund und Esel ist dann schon so...
Ich habe mit denen nichts gemeint. Ja, und deswegen sind auch Hunde immer verwirrt, wenn sie Füchse sehen.
Ja.
Es ist immer so, grüßt man sich jetzt?
Ja, grüßt man sich oder nicht? Guckt man auf dem Boden und läuft aneinander vorbei?
These, ich glaube, Fuchs zu Hund ist wie Holländer zu Deutsch.
Okay.
So im Ausland, aber im Ausland.
Ja.
Also Deutsche würde man irgendwann vielleicht mal begrüßen, so, hallo, sind wir auch Deutsche, tolles Essen hier auf Gran Canaria, ja, tolle Insel, mag ich auch lieber als Forteventura, sowas.
Aber mit einem Holländer wird es wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Aber vielleicht, man weiß nicht genau, weil Holländer spricht auch auf Deutsch.
Es ist diese unangenehme Nähe, wo man nämlich nicht weiss, ob man grüsst oder nicht.
Weil es gibt ja so, ich meine, dass sich ein Esel und eine Qualle nicht grüssen, geschenkt. Geschenkt.
Ja, also da muss ich nicht einen Cent für bezahlen.
Das ist, natürlich nicht. Generell glaube ich, dass Quallen nicht häufig Hallo über die Straße brüllen. Ja, kann schon sein. Weil ich wüsste nicht, wo ihr Mund ist. Ja, oder vielleicht eine von ihren Fühlern, Tentakeln, Dornen, mal so kurz zum Gruß, Servus, hochschnellen lassen,
aber das ist klar, aber Pferd und Esel,
Giraffe und Pferd, das sind alles diese
ganz unangenehmen kleinen, ich glaube,
deswegen haben sich Tiere auch so entwickelt,
dass die nicht alle durchmischt leben.
So wie Menschen, die leben ja
alle durcheinander.
So Tiere, da leben die Füchse da
und die quallen da.
Abgesteckte Territorien.
Genau, und die kommen nicht zusammen, weil es halt einfach zu unangenehm ist mit den Grüßen.
Löwe und Tiger, auch so. Sind wir Feinde, sind wir Freunde, sind wir gleich?
Sind wir dasselbe?
Wir kennen das Ziel.
Eigentlich, wir sind auf derselben Seite, aber auf unterschiedlichen Erdhälften.
Ja, das stimmt, die sehen sich nie, ne?
Kleine Frage an dich. Kleine Frage, freue ich mich. Kleine Frage, und zwar, es gibt ja, haben wir gerade etabliert, danke, Tiere, die näher aneinander liegen als andere Tiere. Also Mensch und Affe liegen nah beieinander, weil der gemeinsame Vorfahre vor relativ kurzer Zeit existierte, sagen wir mal. Wohingegen Mensch und Qualle sind auch verwandt, haben auch einen gemeinsamen Vorfahren, aber der ist schon, huiuiui, der ist schon sehr, sehr alt. Also von dem gibt es nicht mal mehr Fotos, keine Audioaufnahme, der ist weg. Jetzt kommt die Frage an dich. Welche zwei heute lebenden Tiere sind am weitesten voneinander entfernt? Welche zwei heute lebenden Tiere sind am weitesten voneinander entfernt? Also die haben wirklich nichts miteinander zu tun. Also so gar nichts. Ich glaube, auf der einen Seite hätten wir dann so was super Überzüchtetes, also was maximal unnatürlich weit weg gezüchtet ist, Beispiel irgendeinen Hund, so ein Mobs, ein kleiner Mobs, und dann so was super Altes, wirklich wie Qualle oder so ein Tiefseefisch. So alt? Ja, so alte, die man auch so aus den Was-ist-was-Dinobüchern noch kennt. Okay. Dinge, die sich nicht verändert haben und damals schon so waren, wie sie sind. Also du sagst Mops und Qualle. Ich sag, nee, ich würde sagen Mops und so ein Tiefseefisch. so ein Knochenmeister. Mops und Tiefseefisch mit dieser Leuchte vor sich. Der Anglerfisch, ja. Der Anglerfisch. Alles klar, danke für die Antwort. Was willst du sagen? Also ich wäre jetzt auch an die Qualle gegangen, ich wäre direkt an die Qualle gegangen und ich qualle und dann vielleicht irgendwie so ein Hamster und Specht oder sowas, der wirklich, aber auch Abneigung einfach, aber ganz kurz als Hausaufgabe, falls ihr Biologen seid da draußen, das Wort Mangrove benutzen in einer, Mangrove, herrlich, oder Atoll oder sowas, die leben in Buchen, wir sind noch bei M. Oh Gott, okay. Wir arbeiten uns von M nach A und dann ab M weiter nach Z. Ja. Mangrove. Also, falls ihr beruflich das Wort Mangrove benutzt, dann schreibt uns gerne, welche heute lebenden Tiere sind am weitesten Moment entfernt. Die würden sich nicht einladen. Auf Partys. Also niemals, die würden sich nie zu einer Hochzeit einladen oder nie ... Aber kurze Frage, du hast ja für uns als Worst Bird Production Company, hast du die Verleihung zum Vogel des Jahres geschaut. Vogel des Jahres? Was ist da, kannst du uns kurz einen Abriss geben? Also Vogel des Jahres wurde dieses Mal, dieses Jahr das erste Mal demokratisch gewählt. Bislang immer hinter ... Ist das schon die richtige Entscheidung überhaupt? Nein, hinter verschlossenen Türen normalerweise wurde der Vogel des Jahres einfach so gekürt von Experten. Wie Nobelpreise. Richtig. Und dieses Jahr wurde das erste Mal der Öffentlichkeit überlassen. Jeder konnte abstimmen über den Vogel des Jahres. Und natürlich war Unsicherheit, welche Kriterien denn bitte herangezogen werden sollen für die Vogel des Jahres Wahl. Jetzt gab es viel Einflussnahme, denn wenn du diese Liste der Vögel gesehen hast, dann stand bei jedem schon fett dabei, bedroht. Wählen, wählen, nicht wählen, nicht bedroht, bald bedroht, also auch Mittel, Mittel, auch Drohungen da drin. Auch Drohungen eigentlich. Werden wir bedrohen, wenn sie nicht die Meise wählen. Genau, das heißt, auch hier lag schon in der Luft, soll man den jetzt wählen, der am meisten bedroht ist? Warum ist der nicht aus gutem Grund bedroht? Also klar, ich will jetzt solche Sachen gar nicht in den Raum legen, aber man kann sich ja schon überlegen, verdient der es überhaupt zu leben?
Also, nein, also du verstehst, also jetzt du guckst mich jetzt.
Ich glaube, ich habe dich falsch verstanden.
Also du hast mich, glaube ich, falsch verstanden, ich meine es nicht, aber man darf ja, also ich finde schon.
Also haben doch alle ein Recht zu leben.
Ja, klar.
Musst du mir einfach zustimmen,st mir einfach zustimmen. Ja. Und dann gab es eben diese Auswahl. Es gab dann noch die Top Ten der Vögel. Irgendwann wurde die Top Ten gewählt, die dann noch mal in die nächste Wahlrunde ging. Und da hat sich natürlich auch die Öffentlichkeit regelbeteiligt. Viele Leute aus der Öffentlichkeit haben sich dazu beteiligt, haben schmierige, widerliche populistische Hetzkampagne gefahren, also erbärmlich.
Und letzte Woche wurde dann der Vogel gewählt.
Mein Favorit war der einzige Vogel, der schon zweimal Vogel des Jahres war, die Feldlärche. Warum? Das ist für den Favoriten. Ich bin für den, also mein Ziel ist, dass sich in 20 Jahren Menschen fragen, was zur
Helle war da los, warum gewinnt der dreimal Vogel des Jahres, vor allem der hat letztes Jahr schon Vogel des Jahres gewonnen, das heißt, der würde zwei Jahre in Folge gewinnen. Leute lieben, die fällt nicht. Und alle Generationen in Zukunft würden sich fragen, what the fuck, was war da los, was für ein krasser Typ. Gut, wir hatten so Pandemie-Scheiss, aber warum ist das denn passiert? Was für ein krasser Typ, deswegen war ich für die Feldlerche. Und enttäuschenderweise wurde die Feldlerche Platz vier. So. Und Platz eins ging an das Rotkirchen. Och, lame. Hä? Super lame. Aber klar, das passiert, wenn man die Öffentlichkeit abstimmen lässt. Ja, Rotkirchen ist halt, klar, der Bekanntheitsgrad ist hoch. Bedroht denn? Leute kennen die Rotkirchen. Sind Rotkirchen bedroht? Nee. Nein? Null. Ja, gut. Und wann wird der The Worst Bird prämiert? Ja, The Worst Bird ist ein bisschen schwieriger auf jeden Fall, aber mich würde natürlich auch interessieren, weil die haben ja jetzt die Daten. Naboo heißt dieser Bund. Der Planet. Ja, der diese Umfrage macht. Und die haben ja die Daten. Super heftig, Naboo. Ja. Und die haben ja die Daten über die ganzen Stimmen.
Und damit die ja die Top Ten rausfinden konnten,
müssten die ja auch die Daten haben.
Die müssten ja theoretisch auch wissen,
welcher Vogel am allerwenigsten Stimmen bekommen hat.
Und das wäre natürlich unser Worst Bird 2021.
Der schlechteste. 120 Vögel wahrscheinlich, die alle null Stimmen bekommen hat. Und das wäre natürlich unser Worst Bird 2021. 120 Vögel wahrscheinlich, die alle null Stimmen bekommen haben. Weiß ich gar nicht. Also ich glaube, es war über 100.000 Stimmen beim ersten Mal auf irgendwie so 200 Vögel oder so. Da kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass da jeder mindestens eine Stimme hat, aber kann gut sein. Also da würde ich gerne jetzt mal hier kurz Naboo gerne weghören, da würde ich da gerne einbrechen und die Zahlen klauen. Okay, jetzt mal ganz kurz, wir sind ja unter uns, wir sind jetzt mittlerweile im Darknet, das glaube ich, man muss es nur sagen, wir brauchen Hacker von euch, haben wir Hacker im Publikum und dann würden wir nämlich uns gerne mal auf die Server. Das finde ich so einen geilen Liebstahl, weil, klar, Banken werden überfallen, so Juwelen, Schmiede, Schmieden werden überfallen. Aber bei der Naboo kann man doch ganz einfach einbrechen. Wo haben die denn ihre Laser auf dem Boden? Weiss ich nicht. Die haben keine Laserböden. Die haben keine schusssicheren Westmahnen. Aber die haben doch die Leute mit den roten Uniformen, die so machen oder nicht. Das stimmt ja, die Gungens. Und die haben überall diese Lichtbarrieren. Sollte mal ein Kampf ausbrechen. Sollte mal ein Kampf ausbrechen, machen wir rote Lichtbarrieren. So würden diese Lichtbarrieren diesen Kampf für eine Minute verzögern. Verzögern, aus dramaturgischen Gründen verzögern. Also ich würde schon schon sagen, dass Nabu durchaus nicht schutzlos dasteht. Ich würde sagen, wir nehmen Nabu ein. Das ist mein, also auch aus anderen, weit woanders gelagerten Interessen würde ich gerne Nabu einnehmen. Und das hat jetzt was mit dem, mit der Handelsföderation zu tun? Nee, Vogel des Jahres. Ach so, sorry, ich finde das immer so verwirrend ein bisschen, aber gut. Ich auch, aber ich finde es auch cool, wenn wir Naboo einnehmen. Okay, aber du glaubst nicht, dass die dann irgendwie so, sag ich mal, so Freunde aus dem Unterwasser haben, die dann den beistehen. Was, Nein. Nein? Okay. Nein, das ist ein friedliches Volk. Okay. Gibt so ein paar Lebensformen. Nicht, dass da der Fisch des Jahres dann noch eingreift. Es gibt immer einen größeren Fisch des Jahres. Die meisten Hörer verstehen wahrscheinlich kein Wort gerade. Aber finde ich eine gute Idee, klar Anstiftung zu einer Straftat ist natürlich immer ungern gesehen, aber trotzdem hauen wir es mal raus. Falls ihr Zugang habt, falls ihr dort arbeitet, falls ihr Whistleblower sein wollt, falls ihr Whistlepfeifer werden wollt und sagt, da läuft was schief, gebt uns gerne die Zahlen, oder falls ihr Nabu selber zuhört, gebt uns gerne die Zahlen, wir wollen den Worst Bird kühren. Wir wollen den Worst Bird kühren, ja, das finde ich super, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Vielleicht schon nächste Woche, vielleicht klappt's, und dann schauen wir mal, wie das funktioniert. Dann schauen wir mal. Ich wünsche allen Hörern eine fantastische nächste Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche, schau zu, zu sagen. Genießt es. Genießt es. Und ich würde sagen, diese Woche keine Hausaufgabe, oder? Diese Woche Hausaufgaben frei, weil alle so toll waren. Ihr wart so gut, ihr habt diese Woche keine Hausaufgabe, nur an, wie gesagt, Biologen, schickt uns eine Mail zum Thema. Aber an diesen szenischen Umsetzungen würde ich gerne, da hätte ich gerne noch im Hinterkopf behalten, dass wir vielleicht mal die Hausaufgabe aufgeben, dass Zuschauer so kleine Szenen für uns spielen müssen. Das machen wir. Aber wovon? Die Szenen aus dem Podcast-UFO nachspielen. Ja, genau. Ihr könnt irgendwelche Szenen oder Gespräche aus dem Podcast-Ufos szenisch nachstellen und schickt sie uns.
Veröffentlichen wir auf Instagram, folgt uns auf Instagram, ansonsten hau rein. Aber müsst ihr nicht machen.
Nee, entfolgt uns.
Habt eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, wir haben ab.
Ciao!
The Worst Bird Production.